basically the number of problems that
the brain finds is always the same yes
and so all you do is switch the things
that you see are problems the easiest
way to solve a problem with this side is
not a problem to begin with it's just
the mind's function yeah it's supposed
to do that because trying to keep you
alive yeah trying to determine right
like the really happy monkey probably
didn't do as well as the paranoid monkey
that was watching out for Lions because
the happy monkey's like dude
you know what I mean right but the other
one that was like I don't know I don't
know I don't know like this place did
you hear that did you hear that like
stressed out his mind like he's he's up
in the tree and the other guy's like
it's fine it's always the rain relax and
then done yeah you're always giving the
same level stressed out just have those
good problems to focus on yeah champagne
problems